FTX man yeah dude how are you getting
your money out I mean that whole thing
is [ __ ] crazy I guess we haven't
talked about that have we you saw a clip
of her riding his face what yeah
no [ __ ] off yeah no way yeah
no no really gosh it's like selfie and
she's like sitting on she's like
oh my God because they're they're
supposedly a sex tape coming out I think
it's fake but someone like made a
website I was like what come on dude
this story is so weird that would not
surprise me I know it wouldn't but
that's the part where it's okay
what
I mean apparently they did there's like
a there's there is a picture that I saw
of like a hot tub and a bunch of FTX
employees and they're all naked
okay that picture exists
and I think it's real yeah here's the
this is the website it says SPF and
Caroline
uh must be held accountable 11 18 2022
their sex tape will be released onto
this uncensorable web page
and then 11 18 came and the website
updated it was like we need more people
to see this
[Laughter]
it's like more eyeballs need to be on
this website we're not releasing it yet
is that okay
come on but I mean that his text
exchange with the Vox reporter
was I didn't read that yet oh my God
guys if you are unaware I don't know how
you could be I mean this is like
literally one of the best stories most
not best because I know like a lot of
people like lost their entire
livelihoods but I'm just saying most
entertaining
wildest [ __ ] stories in the last like
decade compelling for sure yeah okay
as Vox reporter says you said a lot of
stuff about how you wanted to make
regulations just good ones was that
pretty much just PR2 wait wait by the
way let's just say like this is the
story of FTX one of the biggest crypto
exchanges in the world the second
biggest in fact
this kid started it his name is sand Sam
bankman Freud he just goes by SBF was
the second biggest Exchange in the world
it's like something like five years old
or something like that yep started it
and like just he started by doing
Arbitrage with Bitcoin so he would buy
Bitcoin
in America I think and then sell it in
Korea or something like that and
and made a bunch of money on that
Arbitrage started FTX with that money
basically grew into the second biggest
uh crypto
um
uh what's the [ __ ] word I'm looking
for exchange and then off that started a
hedge fund called Alameda that were
sister companies
and uh basically no one really knew how
they were related turns out
after everything collapsed which I
recently just did
um he lost 10 billion dollars worth of
value basically that they found out was
just
uh lost via him stealing it
for Alameda from clients yes does that
make sense yes I mean I think it's a
pretty bad job of explaining that but uh
I I think it's Financial meltdown since
birdie Madoff and the biggest scam since
Bernie Madoff yeah it's one of the
biggest
out there and you know his dad is uh
what didn't he used to work for the SEC
I don't know about his dad I thought he
had some connection to the SEC
um
Maybe
either way I know all the details but
Joseph bankman uh both professors at
Stanford law school or maybe just an
economist then I just thought he had
some like nepotism connection to the uh
like to the SEC and in that it sort of
highlighted he should know about fraud I
think that that's kind of the
implication there whatever point is he
operated in proximity to powerful people
yeah that's all I'm trying to highlight
here because he also donated a lot yep
to uh the Democrats and also to like
media companies and he just gave away a
[ __ ] ton of money and so when after this
whole thing collapse people have been
like okay what was this guy really an
evil dude why did he give away so much
money if he was stealing money
and like committing fraud in the process
like who is this guy is he the devil New
York Times Are this big piece on him
um that they kind of got torn up for on
Twitter but it was basically like
saying that he he it was just really
just a mistake he like he really didn't
know what was going on and it was an
accident that he like lost his money
like it wasn't fraud yeah like they
didn't they don't say the word fraud one
time yeah
and yeah he had no idea yeah exactly he
had no clue and so then all of a sudden
Vox releases this article and they're
like we've been dming him these are the
DMS and he posted it on his own Twitter
and they're like this is real I didn't
really think we were talking on the
record but this is real I did say these
things so like I said he did some
interviews where he was like I'm gonna
give away my entire Fortune he donated a
lot to political causes he gave away a
lot of money
and didn't even say he's like I'm not
going to keep any of my money or
something yeah yeah he said in the thing
he's like I'm I'm vegan first of all I'm
also like he was just like this guy that
would profess a lot of or this like
established like moral code and yeah
yeah and uh ethics and stuff like that
so the reporter says the effort so the
ethics stuff mostly up front people will
like you if you win and hate you if you
lose and that's how it all really works
and he said yeah I mean that's not all
of it but it's a lot
the worst quadrant is sketchy plus lose
the best is Win plus question mark
question mark Clean Plus lose is bad but
not terrible so he's basically like if I
get caught for these things
like if I don't get caught then and I
win that's like the best quadrant to be
in yep it's like when you know yeah yeah
is that what he's saying I think so so
then he said then the reporter said you
were really good at talking about ethics
for someone who kind of saw it like all
as a game with winners and losers he
said yeah he he I had to be it's what
reputations are made of to some extent I
feel bad for those who get [ __ ] by it
by this dumb game we woke westerners
play where we say all the right
shibboleths and so everyone else likes
us uh oh dude isn't that crazy do not
let Mr Alex Jones get his hands on this
seriously yeah
uh oh but is it crazy like him just
dumping all this like yeah I just was
[ __ ] like I knew that this would make
me look good so and you know what
there's going to be a weird cohort of
people who go
I kind of [ __ ] with it with that yeah
yeah seriously I mean you know he's just
doing I mean so we do every day man when
we get up and clock in you know yeah
just sucking the man yeah
we're just [ __ ] the man aren't we
yeah
yeah on this note of like crazy ass CEOs
can I just pivot sure yeah I don't know
I'm sorry if it was boring I just
thought this this whole story is so
[ __ ] interesting also apparently
Michael Lewis has been following him
around
because he was writing a book on him and
now he's like now this is gonna be the
best book of all time oh let me shout
out this lady on Tick Tock she was kind
of echoing this idea that Tom Brady's
divorce might be because of the FTX
promo okay yeah apparently they lost a
[ __ ] ton of money okay I've seen some
[ __ ] it's probably [ __ ] but about
like their whole Fortune being her name
and FTX yeah her name is culture work
she kind of just joins in on this Theory
like okay if you put Tom Brady and
giselle's divorce through like the lens
of FTX let's kind of look at what
happened here I can't rephrase
everything she stated but it was just
sort of putting the idea or she's biting
on the conspiracy that maybe they needed
to divorce to do some weird thing to
like recuperate their funds or something
like that okay uh and them being
divorced like maybe was like crucial in
like the structure of their relationship
but it happened before this whole thing
melted down what them getting divorced
yeah that's why it's conspiracy like
it's sort of
but there she was saying like maybe they
had Rumblings of or or not her
specifically but I think people were
putting the idea out there that maybe
they knew something [ __ ] was up with
this kid so they
kind of orchestrated this divorce
to maybe collect some of their funds or
like move their funds to like a hidden
place right then it's protected from
whatever because I don't know
as conspiracy